To understand what symmetry is let's draw an Isosceles triangle.
It's a triangle in which two of its sides are equal.
Now let me give you an easy task.
You need to think if we can divide this triangle into two parts
such that both the parts match
exactly when they're folded along a line.
How would you divide the triangle if this condition has to be satisfied?
Fold it along a line such that both parts formed match exactly.
Pause the video and give it a shot.
It's easy, and I'm sure most of you would have got it right.
If we draw a line like this the condition will be satisfied.
Yes, it's a vertical line which divides the triangle into two parts
which match exactly when folded along the line.
If the part on the right is taken over to the left
we see that they overlap exactly.
And that is why this shape is said to be symmetrical.
The two parts match exactly when folded along a line.
Now let me give you another figure.
I draw the Isosceles triangle this way and ask you the same question.
How would you divide the triangle into two parts
such that both the paths match exactly
when they are folded along a line?
Yes, we can draw a horizontal line like this.
We get two paths which match exactly.
When one is folded or flip it overlaps exactly over the other.
Both these lines we see here
are called the lines of symmetry
or the axis of symmetry.
This triangle has a vertical axis of symmetry as this line is vertical.
And this one has the horizontal axis of symmetry as this line is horizontal.
Now I want you to think about the next question I am going to ask you.
Can a shape have more than one axis of symmetry?
If you look at just these two triangles, you must probably say no.
Because there is no other line
which can divide these triangles
into two parts that match exactly.
But the correct answer is that a shape
can have more than one axis of symmetry.
Look at this rectangle.
These two parallel sides are equal.
These two parallel sides are equal ,
and all four angles measure 90 degrees.
It will have a horizontal axis of symmetry like this.
When one part is flipped over it will overlap exactly with the other.
And it will also have a vertical symmetry like this.
Flip this part and we see the perfect overlap.
So a rectangle has a horizontal as well as a vertical line of symmetry.
But wait..
Some of us may be wondering
if the diagonals are also the axis of symmetry.
Let's say we have a diagonal like this.
You can see that folding it along the diagonal does not give us matching parts.
You can try this with a page from your notebook.
Try and fold it along the diagonal
and you will see that the parts do not overlap exactly.
Okay, here's another question for you.
Can a figure have more than two axis of symmetry.
If yes then which figure?
Again the answer is yes.
Take the example of a square.
All its sides are equal and all four angles are right angles.
It has the horizontal as well as the vertical axis of symmetry
just like the rectangle.
But for a square the two diagonals will also be the axis of symmetry.
If we fold it along this diagonal the parts match
and even if we fold it along this diagonal
these two parts overlap exactly.
So a square has four axis of symmetry.
Horizontal, vertical and the two diagonals.
More than four, what if we have a figure like a regular hexagon?
A regular hexagon is a closed figure with six equal sides
and six equal angles.
How many axis of symmetry does a regular hexagon have?
Pause the video and try to arrive at the correct answer.
Okay, let's see. The horizontal and the vertical ones are obvious.
These two diagonals would also be the axis of symmetry.
Do you think there are any more?
Yes, the line joining the midpoints of these two sides
And the line joining the midpoints of these two sides
will also be the axis of symmetry.
Folding the figure along any of the lines
will give us matching parts, six in all.
And a circle on the other hand has infinite axis of symmetry.
No matter how we draw the line passing through the centre,
the two parts formed will always fold perfectly along that line.
Did you know that nature love symmetry.
The best example of symmetry in nature
would be that of a human face.
It has a vertical axis of symmetry.
What we saw in this video is reflectional symmetry.
If one part is kept against a mirror,
its the reflection will give us the other part.
Let's say we keep half the hexagon on this side of the mirror,
its reflection will give us the other half.
Hence it's called reflectional symmetry.
Is there some other type of symmetry too?
Yes, we will cover that in the next session.